[موسيقى]
معبد دندره واحد من اجمل المعابد المصريه
وافضل حفظا كان مركزا لعباده حتحور معبوده
الجمال والموسيقى والامومه
[موسيقى]
في محافظه قنا شمال الاقصر على الشاطئ
الغربي من النيل وفي قريه دندره يوجد واحد
من اهم المعابد المصريه معبد دندره الذي
يعود العصر البطل منذ حوالي 2500 عام
اعمده المعبد تعلوها تماثيل لراس المعبوده
حتحور معبد لاصول مصريه قديمه عندنا اثار
من عهد خوفو من عهد بيبي لكن طبعا المعبد
بيرجع للفتره البطلميه ومعبد مصري من
الفتره البطنيه البطالمه اللي هم جم خلفاء
الاسكندر الاكبر من اول بطليموس الاول لحد
الملك الشهيره كليوباترا السبعه وحكموا
مصر يعني من حوالي بعد نهايه عصر الاسكندر
الاكبر الى 30 قبل ميلاد سيد المسيح وبنو
هذا المعبد العظيم خصص لهذه الربة حتحور
[موسيقى]
ابرز ما يميز هذا المعبد هذه النقوش
والرسومات الملونه التي تزين الاعمده
والاسقف
مناظر وكانها رسمت بالامس القريب للطقوس
الدينيه التي كانت تقام في هذا المعبد
ومنها صور للملوك والاباطره يقدمون
القرابين
الاسم
معبد واحد من اكمل بالكاف اكمل المعابد
المصريه القديمه بني على اساس من الدوله
القديمه في اساس لخوفه المعبد ده في تيجان
اعمده من اروع ما يكون في نقوش من اروع ما
يكون بدا المجلس الاعلى اثار من 3 سنوات
بازاله الاتساخات والتكن لاول مره فتحنا
سراديب كانت مغلقه لاول مره انها تتظاهر
في ثلاث سردين مناظر الابراج الفلكيه
الفريده التي تزين الاسقف تعتبر اهم سمات
هذا المعبد وايضا مناظر لاسطوره اتحاد
حتحور مع كورس الشمس ومنظر الملكه
كيلوباترا وابنها قيصرون وهما يتعبدان
المعبوده هتحور كانت من ضمن اهم المعبودات
في مصر القديمه وكان لها عيد عظيم جدا في
الفتره اليونانيه الرومانيه وكان لها
ثالوث مكون من الاب والام والابن في هذا
المعبد ومن خلال قامه الطقوس من خلال
الكهنه اللي موجودين في هذا المعبد
معبد حتحور بدندره تحفه فنيه ومعماريه
فريده بين الاثار المصريه سمر بشات لصباح
العربيه من دندره